now before I move on
why is the random variable and the probability distribution together?
Expressed in the form of table. Well, then they're not only expressed in the formal
table. They're expressed also, or they are
visualized in the form of a bar chart.
and scatterplot
And box and whisker plot, I'm sure you've seen
these graphs.
All over the place, they all
different kinds of graphs.
and plot plots
and you always thought you'd probably tell yourself. What do these?
graphs really mean
to generate
histograms, too. Yes histograms, too.
All of these for all of these, you know in order for to be
to in excuse me in order for it to be able to visualize.
statistics
you first need to produce.
a random variable
with its corresponding probably distribution
And that can be a table, which is quite basic or you can if now
when does visualization come in handy is when you have a huge
data set.
Here, maybe we don't need that. We don't need a graph here like we
can.
See it in our heads what that graph would look like but once you have a big numbers, we
have a huge data set if a big sample space.
Okay, and you have many events with different
outcomes.
That's when visualization comes into play.
That's when seeing a trend in upward Trend or a
downward trend.
becomes obvious
But first, of course, you need to understand the mathematical notation.
Okay.
now
the probably distribution describes the probability of the values
within a random variable.
Similar to the probability Mass function is something called
the cumulative distribution function.
now listen carefully
there are three kinds of probability distribution
functions.
Let me type them in here.
three kinds of probability
distribution functions
I'll probably distribution that would lower describes
the probability of values and random variable the probability
distribution function.
or functions
the first one
Is the probability Mass function?
Also known just by probably distribution. So these two things are
identical keep this in mind.
distribution
the second one
is called probability.
density function
PDF
this is related to continuous random
variables.
Remember the number numeric system I told you about we had whole numbers
integers.
And then real numbers.
When we get into real numbers when we get into continuous numbers.
That's when we talk about probability density function. Why are
we not doing it today? Because
in order for you to understand probably density function.
Or working with continuous numbers or continuous quantities
and statistics probability. You need to know
calculus at least single variable calculus.
Integration differentiation, but let's leave that for later.
We won't cover this here. The third one is
called the cumulative.
distribution
function and this
is used both for continuous and discrete
numbers.
Okay.
Both for discrete random variables and continuous random
variables. So remember there are two types
of random variables.
two types
one is discrete.
Discrete, that's one type.
and one is
continuous
That's also another type.
In this session, we are concerned with this type.
because we don't have to deal with Calculus and
similar
Calculus series and sequences. So two
types of discrete. Yeah and also for
a probability distribution
There will be discrete public distribution continuous public distribution, but there are
three kinds of functions that generate these probabilities probability
distributions. Pmf PDF CDF.
So we've looked at this one now. Let's look at this one.
Okay, we're here now.